[Música]
el gobierno de Ecuador rechazó la
petición de la confederación de
nacionalidades indígenas en la que
pedían la dimisión del presidente
Guillermo lasso por la supuesta
incapacidad del mandatario de gobernar
este viernes la organización anunció el
fin de un proceso de diálogo con El
Ejecutivo
el gobierno de Perú hizo oficial la
salida de su embajador de México esto
después de que la presidenta Dina
boluarte acusará a su homólogo mexicano
de injerencia en asuntos internos por su
parte el presidente mexicano mantendrá
su presentación su representación
diplomática en el país andino
el gobierno salvadoreño trasladó a los
primeros 2000 presuntos pandilleros a
una nueva mega cárcel era un avance en
su guerra declarada contra las pandillas
si bien han disminuido los índices de
violencia en el país ha traído consigo
decenas de denuncias por violación de
Derechos Humanos
Bienvenidos a este Informativo en el que
actualizamos las noticias del continente
americano comenzamos en Ecuador porque
el gobierno llamó a la convivencia
pacífica después de que este viernes la
confederación de nacionalidades
indígenas del Ecuador pida la renuncia
del presidente Guillermo lasso la
organización argumenta que El Ejecutivo
no ha cumplido con lo pactado entre las
partes en junio del año pasado y llamó a
una nueva jornada de movilizaciones El
próximo 8 de marzo
ruptura de diálogo en Ecuador el viernes
la conai la confederación de
nacionalidades indígenas anunció que no
continuará las conversaciones con El
Ejecutivo ante una supuesta falta de
interés político para resolver los
problemas del país exigió la dimisión
del presidente Guillermo lasso y pidió a
la asamblea nacional que comience un
juicio político de censura contra el
mandatario Señor Guillermo
renuncia al país y de un paso al costado
frente a las acusaciones que pesan sobre
él y su círculo más cercano por supuesta
estructura de corrupción en las empresas
públicas Pero el sábado el ministro de
gobierno Enrique galón rechazó el
pronunciamiento de la mayor organización
indígena que calificó de actitud
antidemocrática y afirmó que El
Ejecutivo iba a quedarse a la mesa de
negociaciones
este gobierno está ejecutando Los
acuerdos alcanzados con las
organizaciones del movimiento indígena y
le está dando seguimiento hasta hoy ya
se ejecutó o está en proceso de
ejecución un 90% de los acuerdos el
proceso de diálogo entre el movimiento
indígena y El Ejecutivo había arrancado
en junio del año pasado luego de más de
dos semanas de fuertes protestas a nivel
nacional en las negociaciones del
gobierno se comprometió entre otras
cosas a reducir el precio de los
combustibles subsidiados pero el viernes
la mayor organización social del país
llamó a sindicatos y otros sectores
populares a apoyar una nueva jornada de
movilizaciones El próximo 8 de marzo
la presidenta de Perú Dina boluarte hizo
oficial el retiro definitivo de su
embajador en México se trata de la más
reciente escalada de tensiones en las
relaciones entre lima y Ciudad de México
ante la negativa del presidente Andrés
Manuel López Obrador derrotar a boluarte
la presidencia de la alianza del
Pacífico para la mandataria peruana su
homólogo un mexicano comete injerencia
en asuntos internos Juan pupiales nos
cuenta más
Obrador y boluarte dos rostros de una
alianza comercial cuya fragilidad ha
quedado expuesta desde que el presidente
mexicano se negara la semana pasada a
entregar a Perú la presidencia pro
tempore de la alianza del Pacífico las
relaciones entre Ciudad de México y Lima
han agudizado sus choques y estas
tensiones escalaron en la noche del
viernes he dispuesto el retiro
definitivo de nuestro embajador en los
Estados Unidos Mexicanos y de esta
manera las relaciones diplomáticas entre
el Perú y México quedan formalmente a
nivel de encargado de negocios
Obrador sostiene que entregar la
presidencia Pro temporia Perú es
legitimar un golpe de estado el gobierno
mexicano impulsó a finales del año
pasado la suspensión de la Cumbre de la
alianza del Pacífico prevista para
celebrarse en Ciudad de México por la
ausencia de Pedro Castillo el
expresidente peruano destituido por el
congreso Y actualmente detenido Obrador
ha sido un gran consorte de Castillo
porque yo no quiero entregar
este a un gobierno
que considero espurio
conformada por México Colombia Perú y
chile y creada en 2011 la alianza del
Pacífico sigue a la espera de un nuevo
anfitrión para su próxima Cumbre siendo
su última reunión la celebrada en 2019
en Lima
en la actualización de noticias de
nuestra región ahora vamos al Caribe
porque en el este de Cuba Los Fuertes
vientos han provocado la rápida
propagación de un incendio forestal que
afecta desde hace casi una semana a la
zona de pinares de Nayarit en la
provincia de Holguín desde aire y tierra
los bomberos tratan de contener las
llamas que han consumido al menos 1.300
hectáreas Por el momento no se registran
víctimas humanas tan solo en enero se
reportaron más de 80 incendios
forestales en toda la isla según un
informe de los guardabosques de Cuba y
llegan a la prisión más grande de
América Latina los primeros 2000 reos se
trata del megaproyecto del presidente de
El Salvador nayib bukele una cárcel con
capacidad de albergar a unas 40.000
personas desde que declaró el estado de
excepción en marzo de 2022 los
homicidios han disminuido en el país
centroamericano pero organismos
humanitarios denuncian violaciones de
Derechos Humanos dentro de estas
prisiones marinas ardiña nos cuenta más
despojados de cualquier rastro de
humanidad así llegan los 2000 primeros
presos a la prisión más grande de
América Latina en El Salvador hoy en la
madrugada en un solo operativo
trasladamos a los primeros 2000
pandilleros al centro de confinamiento
del terrorismo esta Será su nueva casa
donde vivirán por décadas mezclados sin
poder hacerle más daño a la población el
megaproyecto del presidente salvadoreño
nayib bukele tiene capacidad para 40.000
personas su construcción fue criticada
por la oposición señalando falta de
transparencia tras la aprobación de la
oficialista asamblea legislativa pero
las duras políticas de bukele contra las
pandillas gozan de una gran popularidad
entre los salvadoreños que dicen
sentirse más seguros en las calles desde
que declaró el estado de emergencia hace
casi un año las autoridades Han detenido
a más de 64.000 personas acusadas de
pandilleros y las tasas de homicidio se
han reducido drásticamente el denominado
centro de confinamiento del terrorismo
situado en la ciudad de tecoluca
darte en la particular batalla del
mandatario contra la violencia
célula célula estamos eliminando este
cáncer de la sociedad sepan que no
volverán a salir caminando del secot
pagarán por lo que son cobardes
terroristas el país centroamericano
tiene la tasa de encarcelamiento más
alta del mundo si bien la percepción de
seguridad ha cambiado en El Salvador el
costo es enorme para la democracia y los
Derechos Humanos como denuncian varias
organizaciones humanitarias que aseguran
que el gobierno incurre en violaciones
torturas y asesinatos dentro de estas
prisiones
noticias de Brasil desde que el
presidente Lula decretó la emergencia
sanitaria en la reserva indígena
llanomami en la amazonía brasileña la
lucha contra la minería ilegal ha
aumentado en la zona las fuerzas de
seguridad equipadas de armas pesadas
intenta desalojar a los miles de Mineros
ilegales que buscan oro Gabriel colché
nos cuenta más
sobrevolando la amazonía las autoridades
brasileñas
intenten combate contra la minería
ilegal en la tierra indígena llanumami
desmantelaron el viernes un campamento
ilegal de mineros en búsqueda de oro
hemos establecido las bases de control
para frenar el suministro logístico de
las actividades ilegales en los dos ríos
principales y ahora Estamos Comenzando
la siguiente fase de la operación que es
atacar estos frentes mineros
cuando llegaron las autoridades la
mayoría de los trabajadores ilegales se
fueron corriendo abandonando su material
pero este minero de 36 años no logró
escapar la minería nunca acabará la
minería es una fiebre es una adicción
vas una vez y nunca quieres irte yo gano
mil dólares por semana en qué lugar de
la ciudad se gana eso según los líderes
de anumami unos 20.000 mineros
clandestinos habrían invadido
violentamente su territorio cometiendo
abusos sexuales contra las mujeres y
causando enfermedades por la
contaminación de los ríos
tenemos mucha diarrea y vómitos aquí no
tenemos salud ni ayuda nada
la minería ilegal en la selva brasileña
aumentó
el año pasado un centenar de niños ya no
mami menores de 5 años murieron por
desnutrición en enero Lula decretó la
emergencia sanitaria en la zona para que
las fuerzas armadas puedan expulsar a
los mineros que se resistan a salir pero
el proceso promete ser largo
y terminamos con imágenes que nos llegan
de la capital estadounidense este sábado
cientos de personas salieron a las
calles a protestar en contra de la
invasión rusa de Ucrania Un día después
del aniversario de este suceso los
estadounidenses junto a la comunidad
ucraniana de la ciudad pidieron más
ayuda a al gobierno de Joe biden con
estas imágenes Nos despedimos sigan con
más en France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]